now the record books list Jose Farrar as
a graduate architect Broadway actor
painter designer director motion picture
star in fact he's done everything from
building a bridge to switching the
calvert Jose Ferran
I'm here to present the scientific or
technical awards and I want to make one
thing clear at the outset the method of
selecting the scientific and technical
awards is different from any of the
others a committee made up of the
ranking technicians engineers and
scientists of the industry spends months
investigating the long list of technical
advances made during the year this means
that if a scientist or technician
receives Academy recognition is
achievement has undergone the most
careful scrutiny of his peers and a
tougher audience doesn't exist
not even this one tonight the statuette
or Oscar for scientific and technical
achievement is not given annually it is
presented only when a giant forward
stride has been made in motion picture
science tonight is only the 6 such
presentation in the history of the
Academy open to a short while ago all
35-millimeter motion picture film in
general use was inflammable it had been
a continuing hazard to the thousands of
people all over the world who worked
with film also it was a threat to our
archive that great mass of contemporary
history which has been recorded on film
after years of effort a new type of
improved safety film has been introduced
for that achievement the development and
introduction of the improved triacetate
safety based motion picture film the
oscar has been awarded will mr. Emory
Hughes accept the Academy Award for the
Eastman Kodak Company
the following achievements have been
awarded certificates of honorable
mention to Lauren L Ryder Bruce H Denny
Robert Carr and the Paramount sound
department for the development
application of the supersonic playback
and public address system in simple and
maybe slightly inaccurate words this is
a radio so tiny that it can be carried
in an actor's pocket this makes it
possible for music or verbal directions
to be delivered to the actor or actress
without interfering with the ordinary
recording a dialogue the idea has
already saved a great deal of time and
led to some rather interesting dilemmas
congratulations gentlemen to mr. M to
mr. M B Paul for the first successful
large area seamless translucent
background
now this one is involved broken down it
means that when you see one of those
scenes with two lovers on the veranda
and the Manhattan skyline in the
background the background will look
better from now on
unhappily this invention does not affect
the actors
anyway congratulations to mr. Paul to
Herbert a Brit for the development and
application of formulas and equipment
producing artificial snow and ice for
dressing motion picture sets out here in
California we don't get a look at much
real snow but this new development would
confuse even an Eskimo it last longer
it looks colder and it feels warmer
congratulations mr. Britt
- andrei kuta and Jacque motto for the
design of the Eclair camera this is a
handheld motorized precision camera with
a direct view of the image while it is
being photographed also it is instantly
interchangeable magazines and accurate
registration this instrument increases
very considerably the mobility of our
cameramen and will make a handsome
Christmas present for June Allyson to
give to dick power congratulations
gentlemen - Charles our daily and -
Steve chill egg and the paramount
engineering editorial and music
departments for the new precision method
for computing variable tempo
flick tracks now the click track is the
device by which in certain difficult
cases the Hollywood musician is able to
fit his music with a visual image on the
screen these engineers have turned a
long time consuming task into a simple
rapid operation and for the first time
made it possible for Hollywood musicians
to get home on time for dinner
congratulations to you
to the International projector
corporation for the simplified and
self-adjusting take-up device for
projection machines this development
reduces to almost the zero point the
danger of fire and film mutilation in
the projectors congratulations gentlemen
and last to Alexander Volkov for the
application to production of the
infrared photographic evaluator you may
not know that actor is being
photographed in both infrared and
ordinary photography in the same
sequence present a problem to the
cameraman because of the variations in
the color values of their makeup and
clothing this new device makes possible
an immediate and exact estimate of these
variations it would also if widely
distributed no doubt recommends wear
business certainly no group in our
industry has knocked at frontiers and
saw improvements so consistently as the
scientists and technicians
congratulations to all
and congratulations to you Joe how this
is me sort of getting my second wind at
least I hope I do